collard alors les insultes colle à la
peau de marc but à 46 ans il ya le
triste privilège d'être l'homme de
paille de la belgique un cri noël
violeur et tueur
anne et vieux avaient 17 et 19 ans julie
et mélissa 8 ans des adolescentes les
enfants victimes du trou et très vite
étiqueté pédophiles mais selon les
experts psychiatres ce n'est pas son
profil
c'est un cas psychiatrique mais quand
même un cas hors norme pense que
vraiment kalev par la virulence la
violence ndioum je sais je pense très
clairement un pervers sadique
c'est pas du tout pédophiles mais en
gros c'est quelqu'un qui est requise la
haine donc qui place sa recherche de
licence dans un rapport à l'autre
d'emprise de violence de fascination
selon les psychiatres qui l'ont examiné
marc dufour rejette sa jeunesse il
grandit a offert de charleroi
peu d'instituteurs eni de cinq enfants
l'homme noir si avec beaucoup de
violence le personnage de sa mère à 16
ans il plie bagage quelqu'un qui a dû se
battre très jeune seul et je répète
c'était pas pour ça que j'ai exclu ces
actes c explique certains comportements
certains mécanismes de défense peut-être
aujourd'hui divorcée sa mère est
toujours installé dans le village elle
et son fils se détestent depuis
longtemps bien la menace d'un bus de la
peur madame lounge vous êtes en contact
encore avec votre fils ou ou pas non pas
depuis combien les amis pourquoi lorsque
nous n'avons pas le même budget mais à
mon sens dans une chose se couvre et ses
filets plus de contacts vous ne voulez
plus rentrer en contact avec votre fils
vous aimeriez bien madame d'avoir un
fils comme ça laisse un fils d'une année
une première fois en 80 6 à 13 ans de
prison pour des enlèvements des
séquestration et du viol de cinq jeunes
filles dont des mineures malgré l'avis
défavorable du procureur général marc
dutroux ne purge que la moitié de sa
peine libre le faire ailleurs vie
d'allocation de trafiquants tout vendre
en prison il s'est marié avec michelle
martin déjà complices de ces premiers
crimes
père de deux enfants il en aura trois
autres avec elle pas de suivi
thérapeutique lui trouve récidive enlève
violent et cette fois élimine ses
victimes
les à aucun moment il ne semble éprouver
de remords lui il a trouvé sa solution
drilles être eu la réponse à sa question
distancié il connaît son mode de jeu
licence il s'y adonne envers et contre
tout pour ce qu'il arrêterait devant les
experts marc dutroux insiste sur son
courage sa philanthropie à l'égard des
plus faibles le criminel n'est pas fou
il est responsable de sézanne